So I'm pretty happy because yesterday we had a nice winter storm and you can see that it's pretty white outside.
It's also pretty sunny.
It's actually brighter on a winter day than it is on a summer day for us here in Canada because the the sun reflects off the snow.
There's a couple things that I need to do today and I'll teach you some English along the way.
One is I need to clean my driveway out.
I'm actually going to blow the driveway out with the snow blower and I'm going to do a little bit of sledding with the kids.
It's actually it's actually hard to walk through this snow right now.
I don't know if you can see.
We're a little bit snowed in today.
When you're snowed in it means that there's so much snow that we can't get our vehicles out.
It is a really nice day though it's it's cold it's minus 15 you don't want to be out here too long without bundling up.
So you can see I have my winter hat on which we call a Tuke in Canada.
I got my winter gloves, got my winter boots, got my winter boots on my feet and I got lots of layers on so I'm nice and bundled up to stay warm.
so the accumulation that's the amount of snow that came down they said was going to be 10 to 25 centimeters I think here we got maybe about 10 centimeters so when it's
this cold outside you want to make sure that you don't get frostbite frostbite is when your skin actually freezes when it's minus 15 you can safely be outside for
quite a while an hour or two but you do want to make sure that you're covered up as much as possible when you're out in cold weather.
We'll go and see if we can get the big tractor started now.
If I lived in the city, I would have to clean my driveway with a shovel or a small snow blower.
Not as fun.
For me it's a lot more fun to clean it with the tractor.
So it's so cold that in order to start the tractor we have to have it plugged in in.
We don't plug our cars in in the winter in this part of Canada, but there are parts of Canada where it's so cold that you have to plug your vehicles in at night just to keep them
warm.
There's a small heater inside.
So we do this with things like tractors around here.
I'm always glad when things start in the winter when it gets this cold.
So this machine here on the back of my tractor is a snowblower and what it does is it'll bring the snow in here and it'll shoot it out through that piece up there.
I'll give you a little video of it working.
That's how you move a lot of snow really really fast.
So probably won't be very easy to see.
It's very safe to drive a tractor at the same time as running a snowblower.
So driveways all nice and cleaned out.
We'll be able to get the vehicles out now when we need to go to work.
I'm not sure if you can see out there, but we have what are called snow drifts.
So snow in the winter will get picked up by the wind after it's on the ground and it will start to drift.
It'll start to build little snow drifts in different areas.
Drifting can be a little annoying because after you've cleaned the driveway, after you've shoveled or blown the driveway out, the wind can fill it back in again.
So that's never fun because then you have to go and clean the driveway again.
I'll probably have to clean the driveway way again a bit later.
So when it's cold and windy at the same time we have something that's called the wind chill factor and the wind chill factor is it'll feel colder than
it actually is.
So right now it's minus 15 that's the actual temperature but with the wind chill it feels like minus 20.
So the real chill factor it actually feels 5 degrees colder and it's cold out here it's so cold in fact that
my camera only works for about five minutes before it says that it's too cold and then it shuts down on me so I've been outside I think four times now to make this video so
we're gonna head behind the house right now we have a hill and the hill has a nice covering of snow on it and the kids are back there sledding they have their sleds out there sledding is when
you get a sled and you go down a hill you slide down the hill on the sled or to bargain we also sometimes use tobogans in Canada but it's a lot of fun so let's go
check it out yeah let's look at the camera hi Bob the Canadian here winter is finally here we're outside doing
some I'm sledding, some tobogganing.
I think I'm gonna go down the hill now.
Okay, you're going first.
Wish me luck.
Okay.
Try not to hit the camera on my way down.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh, oh, that hurt a little bit.
That was a good one.
Well, hey, Bob the Canadian here.
Learn English with Bob the Canadian.
Thanks for helping me clean my driveway.
And for taking a ride down the hill on a sled, don't forget to click the subscribe button below and give me a thumbs up if this video helped you learn some English and I'll see you next week in the next video.
I'm just super happy that we got some snow.
I think most Canadians like snow, not all of us, but most of us.
Anyways, I'm Have a great day.